There are a number of different reasons why values
may be missing from your data. But here are a
couple that I think are particularly common or important.
So, the first is that occasional system errors may prevent
data from being recorded. Another reason that data may
be missing, is that some sub set of subjects or
event types are systematically missing certain data attributes. Or maybe
missing entirely. Let's dive deeper into both of these reasons.
One explanation for missing data is
that something may be failing occasionally when
collecting data. For example, if you
were conducting a traditional door-to-door survey, maybe
the person handling the documents loses a few or tends to miss some
streets at random because they don't know the geography of the town well.